[Musique]
e
peu
ouais
[Musique]
oui
ah ah
[Musique]
oh
la musique souvent ne prends comme une
mère vers n'a pas les toiles sous un
plafond de brume ou dans un vaste et r
je mets à la voile j'ai été pris par la
musique comme un marin est pris par la
mère j'ai été pris par les vents de la
musique je joue d'ailleurs d'un
instrument à vent
je joue du hautbois depuis l'âge de 17
ans et je métamorphose le vent en sont
comme un alchimiste ça reste encore
mystérieux pour moi mais de quelle
métamorphose s'agit-il de celle des sons
ou de moi même
enfants vers 8 ans ma mère m'a inscrit à
l'école de musique et je voulais déjà
faire un instrument à vent de la flûte
traversière et j'ai fait du piano
le piano c'est une immense lire coucher
si la lyre d'apollon et le hautbois le
hautbois c'est le descendant direct de
los de dionysos
lolo c'est l'instrument à vent des fêtes
dionysiaques c'est l'instrument de la
tragédie la tragédie ça veut dire champ
du bouc champ des satires champ des
passions puis donc choisi le hautbois
l'instrument dionysos il y aurait donc
au monde deux formes de musique celle
d'apollon celle de l'harmonie des
sphères et celle de dionysos celle des
passions passion
passion selon saint matthieu de jean
sébastien bach festival d'art sacré de
lourdes
j'avais 11 ans et je chantais dans un
choeur d'enfants et après avoir chanté
le coeur introductif de cette passion de
bach
j'écoutais très attentivement alors
qu'istres les voix solistes le coeur
adulte quand soudain dans cette grande
nef de la basilique du rosaire le son
d'un hautbois s'étaient élevées ces
mélopées ce timbre si particulier mon
enveloppé entouré transporter puis le
ténor a répondu à cet appel du lot bois
puis le coeur puis moi c'est mon coeur
qui a été pris par cet appel de la
musique par cet instrument l'aubois
c'est le début de ma passion qui est
venu justement avec une passion de bach
c'est étonnant cette passion c'est venu
comme une voie vers os x mais aussi
c'est devenu une voix vo yeux ma voix
mon chemin et quand je regarde 40 ans en
arrière
je me dis que quand le coeur parle et
qu'on l'écouté attentivement bien alors
comme une révélation une évidence
ensuite entre cette révélation cette
évidence et la réalisation il peut se
passer du temps beaucoup de temps
parfois les obstacles qui si nous était
présentée à l'instant de cette
révélation nous ferait fuir à tire
d'aile
mais pour moi c'est la magie notre élan
vital qui sait nous protège et
inconsciemment des obstacles à venir
les parents eux avec amour avec peur
aussi parfois veulent protéger les
enfants des obstacles qu'ils voient ils
en oublient souvent d'écouter l'élan
vital chez leurs enfants
alors pour moi de cette expérience je me
dis que notre rôle de parent
d'éducateurs c'est d'accompagner cet
élan vital chez les enfants pas de
tenter de le détourner
entre l'âge de 11 ans et l'âge de 19 ans
donc j'ai résisté
j'ai résisté à une voix qui semblait
facile évidente une carrière dit
brillante être médecin la résistance
c'est la capacité d'un composant a
résisté au passage d'un courant
électrique en produisant de l'énergie
sous forme de chaleur
je pense qu'inconsciemment c'est ce que
je voulais produire de la chaleur de la
chaleur émotionnelle autour de moi
parlons maintenant de résilience on en
parle souvent la résilience en physique
c'est la capacité d'un matériau après
avoir été déformés de retrouver sa forme
initiale et on peut dire que depuis mon
enfance je suis sur un chemin pour
retrouver ma forme initiale mon élan
vital souffle intérieure ce qui m'anime
ce qui me fait mouvoir émouvoir les
émotions
est ce qu'il existe une vraie place pour
les vivres pour les exprimer pour les
partager dans nos sociétés elles
existent certes par l'art mais pour moi
mis au rang de divertissement
avançons un peu j'ai maintenant 21 ans
ça fait quatre ans que je fais du
hautbois c'est ma vie c'est mon métier
c'est ma passion et je suis en grèce à
epidaure dans ce théâtre antique à
l'acoustique parfaite
c'est un matin d'été il est 7 heures je
suis tout seul
et dans cet écrin de verdure et de
belles pierres merveilleux ou raisonnée
les grandes tragédies grecques et les
comédies aussi et où l'os grecque cet
instrument à vent cette review
accompagné aussi ces tragédies et ses
comédiens
j'écoute j'écoute le bruit mais pas dans
cet hémicycle
j'écoute leçon ma voix se propager dans
cette acoustique parfaite
la beauté de ce moment et du duo
m'étreint fortement c'est quelque chose
d'unique pour un musicien d'être là je
m'éloigne donc à regret du théâtre et là
je me rends compte que je suis dans un
ensemble bien plus grand un immense lieu
dédié au dieu de la médecine asklepios
dans ce lieu là je me rends compte que
on soigner autant les corps que les âmes
que les émotions et pour les grecs
soyez les émotions c'est par la tragédie
c'est par la comédie c'est par le
théâtre sous la forme de la purgation
des passions ce qu'ils appelaient la
catharsis chez eux donc de l'art à la
médecine de la médecine à l'art il n'y
avait qu'un pas et alors à ce moment je
saisis mieux ce que j'avais compris
jeunes enfants que l'art est bien plus
qu'un noble divertissement il est une
façon de se relier à soi même de se
relier au monde voire de se guérir
chez les grecs
donc dans la grèce ancienne la catharsis
des passions leurs sublimation dans
l'art la recherche du beau et quelque
chose d'aussi important que la recherche
du bien commun dans le sens moral ou de
ce qui est bon dans le sens des choses
matérielles et si je fais une analogie
entre la recherche du bon du bien et du
beau et les trois états de la matière le
solide
le liquide et le gaz ont de quoi je peut
me priver plus longtemps je peut me
priver de nourriture solide pendant
environ 40 jours je peut me priver de
boire donc de liquide pendant environ
une semaine et simplement de quelques
minutes sans respirer
la respiration le souffle le vent donc
est quelque chose d'essentiel pour nos
corps et donc pour moi notre souffle
l'intérieur l'est tout autant
ça fait maintenant bientôt trente ans
que je consacre ma vie à cette recherche
du beau parent la musique il y à là
dedans quelque chose de l'absence de
fonctionnalités direct et matérielles
une forme de gratuité et parfois de
grâce quand qu'aux musiciens on arrive à
transformer ses émotions dans le son est
que ce sont touche le public
cette recherche du beau pour moi c'est
aussi savoir le voir dans le monde
autour de soi dans l'autre en soi même
c'est beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de
plaisir et aussi c'est un combat c'est
un combat parce que dans nos sociétés
quel temps quel espace est dédié à la
transmutation de nos émotions à la
sublimation nos passions de façon à ce
que elles ne deviennent pas de la
violence verbale voire de la violence
physique mais plutôt un vent libérateur
un vent de partage
la sublimation en physique c'est le
passage de la matière solide directement
à l'état gazeux à celui du vent tiens
tiens
pour moi l'art et donc la musique peut
avoir cette vertu magique de sublimation
de nos passions qui peuvent s'enkyster
dans nos corps pour les libérer dans une
larme
un rire est toujours un plaisir commun
le partage de nos émotions et nos
enfants
ou est ce qu'il existe des piscines de
beauté où ils peuvent nager à loisir ou
et quel temps ils disposent dans leur
école pour se ressourcer se connecter à
leur souffle intérieur à ce qui les
anime vraiment pour moi la pratique d'un
art c'est un moyen de se relier à ce
souffle intérieur à ce qui nous anime à
nos émotions et à nos aspirations les
plus intimes
pour moi ce chemin de la pratique
artistique
c'est un chemin long c'est un chemin qui
demande du temps qui en compensation
procure des joie très profonde et la
joie bien sûr physique sensoriel le
plaisir là ce plaisir émotionnel voire
spirituelle et puis si on revient à de
la médecine
si une façon de mieux connecter nos deux
hémisphères cérébraux le gauche le droit
de libérer l'imaginaire de libérer la
créativité
l'intuition tout autant que la raison
et c'est pourquoi c'est mon chemin et ma
conviction profonde qu'il est absolument
nécessaire pour nos enfants qu'ils
puissent très tôt dès le plus jeune âge
avoir accès à une pratique artistiques
la musique la danse le théâtre les arts
plastiques toute forme d'art et il faut
créer dans nos vies et dans celle de nos
enfants
un temps un espace et des pratiques pour
développer éduqué par l'art notre écoute
notre regard notre ressenti donc par
l'odeur à notre goût et notre touchés et
alors je suis sûr que soufflera dans nos
vies et dans celle de nos enfants un
vent de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité
[Applaudissements]